Okay so
thanks everyone for coming
I'm always happy to be back in Berkeley
just realized I first was here 23 years
ago when I started my PhD so now you can
see how old I am but uh it's always nice
to be back
and uh
I'm gonna talk about Quantum machine
learning in the niskera
and it's not very clear to me what
Quantum machine learning is neither but
niskies so I will try to basically open
a discussion about all of these things
so the goal is that many of us are going
to stay here for a few weeks or months
so just trying to you know start some
conversations and discussions so
you know there will be some new results
some
opinions and some
provocative statements in the talk so
let's see how it goes
okay so this is how I start my business
talk so this is not how I will start it
here so what is quantum machine learning
you take one to mechanics you take
machine learning and then
something amazing happens
but let me try to get more into some
more technical details of what Quantum
machine learning is or what are the
different types of you know work and
research that we are doing that fall
into the category of quantum machine
learning okay
so one of the things that people have
worked a lot on including myself is we
want to to start working on Quantum
algorithms for speeding up machine
learning things so we take something
specific that people do in machine
learning
most of this has to do with linear
algebra because machine learning at the
bottom is basically a lot of linear
algebra so can we use a quantum computer
to speed up some of the computations
that we do while we are doing classical
machine learning right and there are two
types let's say of categories of
algorithms I'm I'm Gonna Be Missing many
things so if you see something that they
flagrantly miss from the list please let
me know right it's not supposed to be
exhaustive it just needs to fit into one
slide so
okay so one type of algorithms is things
that have to do with linear algebra
right I call them hhl type algorithms
right this was
what we did for recommendation systems a
long time ago linear regression support
Vector machines PCA there are all these
results that use equal to computer and
more particular this type of singular
value
transformation algorithms to
in some sense speed up
linear algebra okay we can see how much
we are speeding up or not if these are
you know polynomial or what type of
polynomial speed ups but there is
something that you can work on on this
type of algorithms the second type of
algorithms are algorithms where you can
actually prove a speed up right because
that comes from things like Grover type
Quantum algorithms like amplitude
estimation to compute gradients faster
right and these are mostly would give
you this quadratic speed up
uh on solving the the problem than on a
classical computer and this you can
actually prove it it goes through Global
type arguments okay the hhl types you
can prove what is the running time of
the quantum algorithms but this
algorithms depend a lot on the specifics
of the data in on the instance of the
problem so they have all these
parameters that
in some cases they're better than the
classical ones but they have extra
parameters in the running time that you
have to be very careful to see whether
in practice they give you a speed up or
not things like the condition number of
the matrices the sparsity of the
matrices the law the rank of the
matrices and so forth okay
okay a second type of what we think is
called machine learning is basically
using Quantum circuits as a Quantum
analog of neural networks okay
so again here the many different ways of
trying to do Quantum neural networks
the main idea is that
you know in a neural network you have
some input you take it through some
layer which is some linear
transformation of your input you get
some output right then you apply maybe
some non-linearity then you give it to
another layer and so forth okay so here
the idea is that instead of doing this
classical
again linear algebraic mapping from
input to Output where you multiply your
input with a matrix right and this is
the Matrix that you try to learn
right the idea here is to have your
input pass it through a Quantum circuit
and get some output at the end of the
quantum circuit so you're kind of
instead of doing this very precise
linear algebraic you know matrix
multiplication you are trying to to to
do something similar using a Quantum
circuit okay and we'll see a little bit
more details why maybe this will give
you something more than what you expect
to get from the classical case okay
again here it's very difficult to prove
many things in the neural network
case right it's very difficult to prove
things like doing this quantumly will
always give you a better result than
doing it classically because even in the
classical case is very difficult to
prove precisely which type of neural
networks work or for what type of data
sets they work and so forth okay but
there are many interesting questions
here to to even very theoretical
questions that we can ask okay
okay
so I'll also spend some time in trying
to to give you some ideas about
trying to come up with I mean what you
know one of the things that I've been
trying to to ask myself for the last few
years is
instead of looking at what classical
machine learning people do and just try
to speed it up right is there something
that for which quantum computers are
natively good doing that also has
some applications in machine learning
okay so this could be things that maybe
they're not so used in classical machine
learning some of them are some of them
are not right they have to do with let's
say more difficult
linear algebra or other type of
computations and the question is
can we use this more natively Quantum
algorithm to say something interesting
in machine learning okay so I think you
know if you were at qip last year there
were three four or five talks about
topological data analysis it's not you
know we can talk more about it and if
this is the right use case I will talk a
little bit about this determinantal
point processes learning with subspaces
instead of points and this type of
reinforcement learning with
distributional algorithms that are quite
interesting and to me they maybe at
least there is an intuition why Quantum
should be doing good in these things
okay
I'm gonna finish with a couple more
things there's machine learning for
Quantum data right so this is another
part of quantum machine learning what
happens if you have Quantum data then
obviously you need to do plan to machine
learning because the data is quantum
I don't know of any Quantum data so
I don't know where to find Quantum data
so it would be interesting to understand
if we will ever do machine learning with
Quantum data
and you know
we can discuss it more but
Quantum sensors don't give you Quantum
data in the sense of
highly entangled multi-cubit States they
give you cubits one by one so single
qubits are not Quantum data right you
can write down two numbers it's a
classical data Quantum data that come
from Quantum circuits also are not
really Quantum data you have a classical
description of the circuit it's also
classical data so a lot of this Quantum
data you can also very easily see them
as classical data but it's an
interesting thing to understand where
would this Quantum data will come to us
and then we will have to deal with
Quantum data right
yeah yeah
so you know imagine you have some
process some sensors you know that probe
some system
and they spit out a thousand qubit
entangled Quantum state
so that would be a Quantum data because
you don't know how
it got created by this physical system
that you don't know what it looks like
it's possible you know what I said is
that it's not possible so but you know
yeah
just gives us cubits yeah
I don't think it's very wasteful
to be honest
yeah all I'm saying is that this Quantum
data is very simple Quantum data right
there's single qubits or now they
started doing epr pairs let's say so I
think there will be much
we will get to be able to do classical
machine learning by by taking this data
into classical Data before we manage to
do Quantum machine learning on this type
of quantum data let's see right
okay one other thing is you know this
goes into
also this idea of can we prove an
advantage in Quantum machine learning
right is there anything that we can
prove we can do that it's not possible
to do classically right and there has
been some work recently a very
interesting work that says okay let's
look at the problem that has nothing to
do with machine learning but we know
that the quantum computer is better than
a classical computer
let's say discrete log okay and let's
design a machine learning problem
where solving this machine learning
problem basically would need to solve
the discrete log problem okay so then
you can say okay if I have a quantum
computer I can solve the discrete log
problem I can map you know I can see it
as a kernel I can do this with a quantum
computer and we know that with a
classical computer it's not easy to
solve discrete log so this gives you
kind of improvable separation between
between the two
uh
uh yeah
I think this is a very interesting
theoretical exercise
that made
it's to be seen if it has any impact in
machine learning actually but it's still
very interesting to see what's happening
okay and the last thing so you see that
I cannot write anymore so this is the
last line Quantum inspired machine
learning okay so what do I mean by
Quantum inspired machine learning there
are two different things here that you
can think of one is again
all of the the the set of work that has
come from looking at Quantum linear
algebra algorithms and saying can I do
this with randomized linear algebra
right this is maybe people call it
dequantized you know Quantum machine
learning or dequantized linear algebra
algorithms
uh
so this is one one part right so again
this is very interesting to understand
what kind of separations we have and
what kind of problems really we should
think that the quantum computer can do
something better right but you can see
it also on the other side which is that
okay maybe equal to machine learning or
at least in the nisk era it could be
about doing better classical algorithms
that come from Quantum ideas and this is
not the first time that this has
happened we have been working on Quantum
inspired algorithms for many years
now they have been in machine learning
as well if your goal is to actually
solve the problem I think this is a very
interesting
you know idea of
we have a different way of looking at
things can we take this intuition and
make it into Quantum inspired classical
algorithms that actually work and
actually solve a problem okay so as I
said this decantised one may not be the
right thing if you really want to apply
it in machine learning and use it in
practice but some of the sound volumes
over here for example list topological
data analysis instead of saying okay I'm
not gonna get the quantum Advantage
because of all these new classical
algorithms is actually good because
people in fact do not use topological
data analysis because it's very
difficult to use so if we manage to get
better classical algorithms that's also
I call it part of quantum machine
learning so it's good okay
so now the main question that you know
Umesh asked me to talk about is qml in
the niskera so let's do an exercise
let's see what of this which ones of
these things we could imagine that they
happen in the nisk era
and I haven't defined niskera yet I will
Define it afterwards so that we are
vague enough to to say what we want
let's say so for any definition of
niskera you can imagine
can we fit anything of this into the
knee Scara so
I you know I'll try to not be very
controversial but I'm gonna put Reds and
greens on the different things so read
this thing that let's say we don't know
yet that it's possible but it may become
possible we should just work on it
Greener things that we hope they are
going to be possible so green is better
than red let's say
okay so are we gonna see hhl type
algorithms or Grover type algorithms
happening in the nisk era it's very
difficult
the reason is that it's very difficult
to see quadratic gaps in the niskera
right it's also very difficult to see
hhl type gaps where you need to do let's
say singular value transformation
because the circuits are very deep
so these are amazing Quantum algorithms
but are not simple ones that you can
imagine running them with a few physical
qubits or a few hundreds or thousands of
physical qubits so I will put it right
but I'm happy you know red means that we
should work harder to make it green
that's the that's the goal
I also think that machine learning with
Quantum data we can do it in different
ways so
also this Quantum Advantage ones because
we use problems where we have
provable
gaps things like discrete log or
factoring or things like that it's not
going to be simple to see to see them
happening soon
this is obviously green because these
are classical algorithms I'm just saying
let's get some intuition and do a
classical algorithm so this we can do
and then we have these two things in the
Middle where I want to be a little
optimistic and make them lighter blue
lighter green so it's not very green but
I wouldn't put them red yet so the
question is can we get anything from
this type of stuff
to the green side to the you know to the
niskera side
okay
edit questions on this as I said this is
just so that we have things to discuss
in the next few few weeks
okay so one more slide that I will go to
actually results oh I'm taking too much
time okay so
yeah
oh
I think yeah I mean we can spend another
full workshop on this to me it's things
where
you look at data to understand something
so that you can do
You can predict something afterwards so
it's algorithms that need to learn in
how to do things but
yeah I mean let's discuss it afterwards
but to be honest it doesn't matter you
know let's say anything where
call it algorithms still I would put
very similar kind of things there let's
say right
yeah
even that it's a very good question okay
and I think afterwards we'll have the
chemistry side so this is what will
complete let's say the biggest people
I'm not going to talk at all about
chemistry right okay so what is this
error Let Me Go a bit fast I don't know
exactly what it's nisk and it's not
clear that Jon had a very precise you
know definition when he said Denis era
so
you know I would say something like
hundred to a thousand cubits with
hundred to a thousand depth something
like these Gates
but I wanted to to say a little bit is
is this thing
which is actually what
we have an IBM person so actually IBM is
claiming that this will happen very soon
okay so if we believe what they say and
I'm very happy to believe what they say
it means that very soon we'll have 100
cubits that we can do 100 depth
okay that's a decent size machine
okay there is a caveat that if you want
to get your result
at the end you need to do like many
hours of post-processing but that
doesn't matter I don't want to use it in
practice Lacy but if I can actually get
results from 100 cubits 100 depth then
that's a decent disk machine right so
the question what can we do with this
type of of things right
and then the other question is can I
trade off depth with two bits right so
what is easier I I don't know what is
easier to build somehow I I still think
that this is easier to build but you
know do we have 100 cubits hundred depth
30 000 cubits 20 left
okay
and if you have this small depth you
better need to have all to all
connectivity 20 depths with nearest
neighbor connectivity is not going to
take you very far but if you have all 12
connectivity like in Iron traps and
stuff then logarithmic depth is very
powerful okay so this is my definition
of nisk is logarithmic depth all 12
Quantum circuits or linear depths near
the stable Quantum circuits with with
the same number of qubits hundred to a
thousand let's say okay
again I just came up with it last night
so it's not clear that this is the right
definition of this but if we want to
study a little bit more theoretically
what can we do in the niskera one way of
thinking about it is what can we do with
logarithmic depth Quantum circuits
okay and I'll give you all to all
connectivity now because you cannot
touch all the humids if you have
logarithmic depth let's say yeah
so what I say here is that if if I know
how to get decent results with high
probability for a computation that
happened with hundred qubits and 100
depth then I call this a nisk machine so
there will be some noise but I want to
be able to to to get a decent result
with 90 probability out of this
calculation
so somehow I'm less interested on the
two bits than on the computation
so the way I want to Define it is that
if I can do this computation I don't
care if the Fidelity is good or what
type of Errors I have or you know it
could be that you have worse qubits but
the errors are nice so that the
computation is possible or that you have
better qubits but still you cannot do it
right so I want to have an algorithmic
type of definition of nisk which is I
want to be able to do this type of
computations
yeah
I'm going to be doing 10 but yes
yes
and it seems like yes so you see I have
one one foot on the Academia and the
other on the other side so to be I think
theoretically the first question we
should ask is logarithmic depth circuits
but if you give me something which is a
million times login then this is never
going to happen
right or if if there's but if you don't
have logarithmic type circuits then
already you are screwed let's say but
logarithmic depth circuits are a good
starting point for me to say that
something should be possible right and
then we need to say what happens when n
is 100 or a thousand and log if it is
two times log then you have depth 20.
but it's not the same question I agree
but given that I don't know how to ask
theoretical questions with 100 or 123
I think logarithmic depth is a good
place to start
let's say
but not asymptotic for n equals
Rebellion let's see okay
all right
so
I think this is all I wanted to say be
General and stuff so now I want to give
you a couple of examples of what we have
been doing on trying to get some of
these quality machine learning stuff
into
Disney scare and then in the end I will
say how possible or not it is to
actually get let me do the next era okay
so the first example I want to to show
you is this thing called determinantal
Point processes right so I'm getting
back to this idea that there are some
things that quantum
algorithms or Quantum Computing is good
at doing natively and the question is
are these things interesting
for machine learning or for algorithms
in general and whether we can actually
one more step can we see something like
this Indonesia so the many stages let's
say okay
so what is what what are determinant
Point processes well first of all
you you have a a bunch of points a
determinal point process tells you how
to sample from these points how to
sample sub subsets of these points okay
so here is a Sealy example if you want
to ask for a jaguar
right
your search engine can give you three
cars of jaguar and that's great they're
very relevant results
but the different
engine can give you one car Jaguar the
animal jaguar and the American Football
Team Jaguar okay so this not only are
they relevant but they're also diverse
okay so you add this notion of diversity
on top of your data okay
so a priority I want to to say that this
type of data is more interesting when
you're doing machine learning when you
when you want to learn about data then
this type of data
okay
now mathematically how do we Define
diversity and all of these things it's
very simple you can think of every image
as a point in space right and what you
want to compute is the volume
encapsulated by these points
so let's say I give you these three
points because they're all three cars
they will be close to each other they
will be mapped very close to each other
so if you see at what volume is
encapsulated by these three points it
should be small
if you get one car one animal and one
football team this should be far
in space so if you look at the volume
encapsulated by this point it should be
large okay so the way to to
mathematically capture this notion of
diversity is by looking at the volume
between points
okay
and
one more point to say that this
determinant Point process is I showed
you why they make sense with with images
but actually they were
defined in 75 to define the spatial
configurations of fermions in Optical
beams so these are exactly the
distributions that tell you how the
fermions will be in space when you leave
them in sub-optical
medium okay
so it does have some Quantum you know
native Quantum origin let's say this
idea of the terminal point processes and
we will see that this also leads to a
very efficient Quantum algorithm right
because we are talking about fabulous in
some sense okay
okay so a bit more mathematics what do I
mean by
you know by this notion of volume so the
the definition of the distribution is
very simple you have an N by D Matrix
and the question is I want to pick a d
subset of these rows n right and I want
to pick each one of these D subsets with
with a distribution with a probability
which is proportional to the determinant
of the sub Matrix the square of the
determinant of the sub Matrix okay and
you think of the determinants as the
volume of this thing this is exactly
what it is okay
so the best classical algorithms to do
that after you do some preprocessing
imagine that this has been
orthogonalized so it's an orthogonal
Matrix then you need a cubic time on the
dimension D to actually be able to
sample to create a sample from this okay
but imagine we need thousands or
hundreds or thousands of samples when we
trade and so forth right
so what we what we found is that we have
a Quantum algorithm think of DNN the
same let's say roughly the same order
here we found the quantum algorithm
where you can do the same thing with
depth D and D Square Gates
okay it's not an enormous Gap right so
I'm certainly not going to claim that we
will see in the niskera this particular
Gap but I think it opens the way to
something interesting to do
right
so I have one slide
about how the algorithm works right
and the slide is the following I give
you this or this Matrix this D Columns
of the Matrix which are orthogonal to
each other right and what I tell you is
that you need to be able to construct
this state
where s is just the subset of size d of
this n rows that I had on The Matrix
and the amplitude here should be the
determinant so then I sample s with
probability exactly determinant Square
okay and this is the circuit that does
it I have the same type of circuit for
each one of these D vectors
I do them one after the other and at the
end what I have here is exactly the
state that I want okay so what is this
circuit here we call it
a Clifford loader because it has to do
with Clifford algebras it's just a
circuit
that depends on this classical Vector A1
that you put it in these parameters
let's say
and you can
do them one by one and then get your
outcome here I did something which has
linear depth so this is not good because
then the depth would be D times n but
what we found is a logarithmic size
logarithmic depth Quantum algorithm to
do exactly this this part here so if
this has logarithmic depth then you have
D of them you have D log n depth in the
quantum circuit okay so that's why I
said that this logarithmic depth is an
interesting thing to understand it
wasn't obvious that there should be a
logarithmic way of loading this this uh
these vectors here okay
so this is a Quantum way of loading the
Subspace right this D by D Subspace
which means that you can
um sample from these determinants okay
you can use it in machine learning
because sampling elements is something
that we do for example in random forests
I don't wanna I wanna give you one
example just to understand what what I
mean imagine you have two types of data
you have the purple data and the and the
yellow data okay and you have a lot of
the data in the middle and then you have
some purple on the left and some purple
some yellow on the right okay and now
you want to understand how should I
split
how do what kind of decisions can I make
so that I can figure out if a data point
is purple or yellow okay
so it's pretty simple to see what you
should be doing you should just say okay
if my feature 0 is less than -2 then I'm
going to predict purple
if my feature 0 is more than two then I
should predict yellow and if it is in
the middle then just guess you know
everything is there okay so this is what
we do in these decision trees that we
use in the random Forest right and the
idea is that how easy it is to actually
find these things because here I gave
you a two-dimensional example that you
can see it if I have elements in 150
Dimensions it's not so easy to figure
out what are the the right you know
splits
but in this simple example we did the
test and we said okay imagine that
you're just uniformly picking Elements
which is what everyone does in machine
learning to do random forests versus if
we use this determinant Point processes
to pick substance of the data okay do we
gain anything in this very simple
example
and here is what we gain the probability
that my DPP sampling will actually find
these two correct splits is up here
but if I uniformly pick what will happen
is that I will only pick things from the
middle and then it's not clear that I
will do the right decision right so the
probability that the uniform sampling
will give you the right splits is much
much smaller
okay
again this is a very simple example to
see why dbps are something that in
practice actually work okay
we also tried it in many different data
sets and it actually works in practice
and I have a slide about
can we actually prove mathematically
that using dbps for random Forest is
actually a very good thing to do so what
we can prove
is that DPP is the optimal distribution
to to
reduce the variance for some particular
cases like the linear regression the
support Vector machines because these
are more mathematical
you know decisions
we cannot prove the same for a random
Forest because a random Forest kind of
arbitrarily makes decisions to split you
know on some features should I go left
or should I go right so there's not
enough structure let's say to do it but
if you look at some sort of heuristic
properties of the random forest and you
simplify a bit
the model the same way that we did it in
the previous example what you find is
that
it reduces to something that we know
that the DBP is the best case so at
least in some simplified case the random
Forest you can still you can prove that
the DPP is the optimal distribution to
pick in order to maximize your your uh
your goodness let's say your performance
okay
there is a lot to be done here like I
think there is some very interesting
mathematical questions of are these
distributions can we prove something
more about these distributions when it
comes to all these machine learning
models is random Forest like G boost and
so forth anything that uses these
decision trees
okay
okay maybe last thing because I do want
to speak I have five minutes huh wow
okay so I want to speak okay are we
gonna see them in the nisk era I think
it's
very difficult to see it if we are
sticking with the particular task where
classically you can do it in dtube and
quantumly you can do it like this okay
but this is not the end of the story The
quantum circus can do many more things
than sampling from the dbb we kind of
thought about the DPP because this is
what classical people are doing okay but
these Quantum circuits can do many more
interesting things which is for example
sampling from mixtures of of DBP
distributions or things that classically
we shouldn't be able to do them okay the
quantum algorithms remain the same like
we can still do them very efficiently
the question is are any of these things
actually useful
right it's not very clear right but I
think it's worth understanding what more
can we do from the dbbs for example DPP
is a fermions
if you go to bosons you have permanent
sampling this is also something very
interesting here you don't pick diverse
things you pick close by so you have
determinants you have permanence you can
even go into a superposition of Emerson
permanence
our annual listings useful and
interesting for machine learning it's
not clear because no one has ever used
them right but I think it's worth you
know trying to understand if any
anything can come here
from these discussions
okay I have three minutes so I wanted to
talk about neural networks so
yeah
five minutes okay thanks seven okay good
good because either I will butcher it if
I do it in three minutes or okay all
right this is my last topic the neural
network so I want to to try and
understand
why should we care about Quantum neural
networks what are the things that we can
add to classical neural networks
is there anything that classical neural
network cannot solve you know
so
let me try to Define what is a Quantum
neural network first of all we need to
load some data right as we said we load
some data to a Quantum circuit we do
some
operation and then we see what happens
afterwards okay and this operation is
the one we try to to train so that what
comes afterwards will tell us if it is a
cat or a dog okay
so loading data is is already very
interesting question there are many
different ways of doing it
we are mostly using this thing that we
call a unary amplitude encoding
and I'll tell you why let's say but what
we do is that if you have an
n-dimensional Vector okay we use NQ bits
and we put in the amplitude the
coordinates of the vector and then you
have a United State the United State is
all zeros with one one
okay so you have n States so in some
sense it's very wasteful because I'm
using NQ bits for an n-dimensional
Vector instead of a to do the
n-dimensional vector okay what I gain by
this is that I can also load it in log
depth instead of having an exponential
depth of trying to to load this thing
okay
so this is one way of doing it there are
other General encodings that you can say
I just take each one of the coordinates
and I rotate my qubit okay this is a
different way this is another
interesting way which is that you do
this and then you do a Fourier transfer
you do a hadamar so now this is
all possible zero one States but it has
encoded also in the amplitude the vector
all right once we have a way of loading
the data then we need to have some
parameterized circuit that we will call
a neural network meaning that they
should have some parameters and then we
need to find the right parameters and
this will give us the the trained neural
network
so here what we use again we go back to
fermions
so these are kind of fermionic gates
these Gates here they're all the same
with different parameters and these are
the gates
so it's just a rotation on the 0 1 1 0
Subspace
and an identity on the 0 0 and 1 1.
okay and we put them
in some different configurations okay
what are the properties of this of these
things
they preserve the Hamming weight
meaning that there are no ones that are
created or destroyed right if you put as
an input here something that has three
ones you will end up with something here
that has three ones
okay none of these Gates here changes
the the number of zero in ones it just
rotates between the zero one and one
zero okay
this which means that basically if you
look at the unitary
it is block diagonal
on the subspaces which are the the
Hamming weight subspaces so this is the
hammingway zero the harming weight one
two and so forth okay so the way that
this thing works is basically a
different unitary for each one of these
humming weight subspaces
okay
what is very interesting is that if you
look at this pyramid architecture
this you can prove that this gives you
exactly the orthogonal group on N by n
matrices
which means that if you look at this
Matrix here which is the Matrix that
corresponds to the junary basis
right this is an N by n Matrix and by
tweaking these parameters here you get
all possible orthogonal matrices okay
which means that if I start with an
input which is unary
and I apply this then I'm doing
basically something classical which is I
apply a orthogonal weight Matrix to my
input okay
so at least I can do what the classical
neural network does which is apply a
weight Matrix on my input with the extra
property of orthogonality which is a
very interesting property to have in
machine learning because it keeps your
your features uh uncorrelated and this
gives you the maximum information that
you get so orthogonality is a good thing
classically you don't know how to get
orthogonality apart from orthogonalizing
the matrices which you don't want to do
because it's a cubic operation
but
quantumly you get it for free somehow
okay
so as I said if you put a generic data
loader here basically what this Matrix
does in instead of doing a 2 to the N by
2 to the end unitary you can think of it
as doing just an N by n unitary that
goes back to what the classical thing
would do right the interesting thing
here and this is goes to this Quantum
inspired things is that it was not known
how to do a gradient computation and how
to update this orthogonal matrices by
keeping the Matrix orthogonal so what
people in classical machine learning
were doing if they wanted to keep this
orthogonality was to look at the Matrix
compute the gradients of each one of the
elements this gives you a matrix which
is not orthogonal and then doing as we
did to orthogonalize The Matrix
this is not something you want to do
while you train and this is why no one
was using this orthogonal neural
networks if you look at the neural
network as we said as this this is a way
of parameterizing the orthogonal group
that now you can
compute the gradients in constant time
for each one of them which means that
you can do the entire training of this
orthogonal matrices even classically in
N Square time
so now we know how to get this extra
property without spending any more time
than if we didn't have the property okay
there's not much Quantum here because
I'm saying we're just working in an end
by n space this is classical
but if we don't use the unary loader and
we use a different data loader that goes
to all possible Hamming weights right
then you do have an exponential size
Matrix that is applied
okay
what is usually the problem with this
exponential size unitaries is that it's
not clear whether they will train
because now you're in an exponential
size space this is fantastic because
maybe you can find better Optima
but you're going to get lost very soon
like your gradients will be very close
to zero okay
but what we can prove for these things
is exactly that they are trainable
okay and the reason is that
there is a very linear algebraic way to
define what this matrices are if you
know what this Matrix is that you get
from the parameters here then this
Matrix is here are just the compound
matrices of your original Matrix
so there is a very
precise you know algebraic definition of
what this matrices look like
and if you look at what they do are
basically having DPP distributions on
each row of the matrices
so all of this is very much related
again to fermions to the distributions
of the ferbians and how you can use all
of this to to train neural networks so I
finish here
and I'm going to my you can do
Transformers you have many applications
I'm just going to go to my conclusion
slide
I was very optimistic
everything works everything is great
okay so this is what we said so far I
tried to convince you a little bit that
there is hope
in working on this thing to be able to
get some application in the nisk era
right and by concluding remarks is that
Quantum Computing has the potential to
improve machine learning
Quantum algorithms can provide provable
advantages in the future
if anything works at nisk that it will
probably be qml it's much easier to make
qml worked on chemistry
because chemistry is a very precise
thing qml is not very precise
and if we find something interesting
then it is not going to be TCS provable
but it's going to be machine learning
provable and we can talk about what this
means
Quantum neural networks could provide
advantages
it has to be seen it has to be you know
experimented and see if it works in
practice
and on our way to try to understand what
kind of nisk quantum algorithms we can
get I think we can turn some of these
Quantum ideas in very powerful classical
Solutions and offer a lot to classical
machine learning even today okay all
right thanks and sorry for taking over
time
[Applause]
all right our next speaker is abhinav
kandala from IBM and he's going to tell
us what we can do with a noisy quantum
computer